this is my grandson Finn it's nice to
meet you Heartland star Robert Cormier
has died he was 33 years old
I think it's really great that you're
doing this Heritage Way of logging and
that you're keeping it in the family
I'm I'm just helping out for the day
according to his obituary the
canadian-born actor died on September
23rd and a visitation will be held in
Ontario on October 1st with the service
scheduled for the following day no other
details about his death were immediately
available but ET has reached out to
Robert's rep for comment the obituary
reads in part quote Robert was an
athlete an actor and a great brother he
had a passion for helping others and was
always looking to achieve more he
impacted so many people throughout his
life whether it was family teammates and
Friends Rob's memory will live on
through his passion for art and film as
well as his three sisters who meant the
world to him
Robert played Finn on season 15 of
Heartland and was expected to appear in
The Following Season which premieres
October 2nd you know we do need some
more competitors in the competition
since you grew up around this yeah he'll
do it
Grandpa
well aren't the Wolves take part in the
other events someone's going to
represent the family name right
I guess I'm in he appeared on shows like
designated Survivor slasher and American
Gods and has three projects that are
currently in post-production
transmission volume 1 the intersection
and the antagonist
up TV heartland's network paid tribute
to the actor on Instagram calling him an
amazing talent quote we are deeply
saddened to learn of his passing our
sincere condolences go out to his
friends family and co-workers
the show's account posted about the
tragic news too writing that Rob was a
beloved member of their team quote on
behalf of the Heartland cast and crew
our thoughts are with him and his family
who have asked for privacy during this
difficult time
[Music]